hey guys I'm Ryan right we're gonna
watch this video today called McDonald's
employee gets fired and goes crazy in
st. Paul
is it Minnesota all right it sounds
pretty self-explanatory I'm looking
forward to someone losing their [ __ ]
make the one time I lost my [ __ ]
McDonald's sale yeah I probably also
didn't lose your job
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I see
[Music]
[Music]
Wow that was kind of depressing yeah
that started off like this is funny and
then it was like this is really dark
like I mean clearly that person has some
serious issues and should not be laughed
at I don't know I need come on my
therapist once told me it really doesn't
matter like what you know what condition
you might have you still always will
have a capability of controlling the way
you treat people
oh of course the thing is you also
probably never had an episode that was
filled and then released in front of the
world like that's very different
oh yes in the moment it might be like oh
my god what's that with all that in
reality I mean this person just lost
their job if that's your only way of
making money it's kind of a serious
thing I mean regardless of this I mean I
understand clearly why this person was
probably fired but at the same time like
yeah if you're fired and you were really
relying on that job you're going to lose
your [ __ ] you will and you know some
people cope in different ways but I
thought he was losing his cool because
there was two hours he didn't get paid
for well yeah that's a problem but a lot
of a lot of places do that I mean that's
why yeah that's why it's kind of funny
because he's really overreacting I got
that on footage I feel like guys you
gotta check this video out I'm putting
on the channel I think that is like an
insane it's like at the same time I do
you over the dudes coming from honest to
god I sort of give kudos to video oh
because I can only imagine how many
McDonald's employees and other jobs that
people feel that way and that they just
they just take it up the ass no deal
with it he was like [ __ ] this so there's
a little bit of respect because at the
end of the day it's like he [ __ ] up at
McDonald's
like you same sign though a lot of
people don't realize that McDonald's
actually pays a lot of locations they
play they pay more than minimum wage
which is more than what I make at the
same time you probably made more than me
at the end of the day so get up well you
have totally switched roles from
completely understanding and shouldn't
laugh at him and now you're like hey
probably just made more than I did by
the end of their shift and is
complaining about to last hours when I
have lost hours all the time by counting
errors yeah but at the same time it's
like you just reach your manager be like
hey fix this thank you I feel for this
person I do but at the same time it's
totally uncalled for our tool lost hours
worth losing your job I imagine that it
wasn't like the first incident he's had
their work yeah he's pissed off like it
wasn't like first mistake at McDonald's
this is [ __ ] I'm sure there's a lot
of built-up anger and resentment and
that was just the final blow for him
yeah anyway guys thanks for telling me
about that video that was if you use the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects ELISA has a channel too you
should check that shiz that out even has
a video and Shane Dawson recently
featured not Unchained Dawson's video
Shane Dawson was like I'm going on her
video think about that shoutouts will
continue so go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shoutouts where you can earn
yourself a shout out by saying something
interesting like McDonald's employees
should be treated with dignity and
respect
okay